we're in Colorado mayor because you
chose this place to launch your big gun
initiative and I'm wondering as I sat
there looking at the families hearing
the families because they have heard
this before we're gonna do it we're
gonna get it done there will be some
changes why do you think you're
different this time I understand the
problem you have to go and look at the
victims before you can really understand
what they're going through the emotional
problems they have the financial
problems somebody in your family gets
killed how do you take care of everybody
who's gonna take care of the kids who
pays for the funeral part of the answer
is you got to go out and look at the
problem rather than just talk about it
in academic sense I think if you take a
look at what we did in New York City in
12 years
cut the murder rate in half cut the
number of young people incarcerated in
jails in half brought back those who
were incarcerated from prisons way
upstate where the families couldn't
visit them to back where the families
can help you adjust them to re-entry
into the real world when they get out
we've done all of this and we need to
scale this up across the country but we
just don't need another speech you don't
need another program in fact I don't
even think you need that much money we
always throw used to be millions now we
throw billions at everything it's a
problem of you it's like in - in
education technology's great but you
need a good teacher looking the student
in the eye and empathizing with the
student and building a relationship same
thing is true in solving lots of other
societal problems one of which is guns
you've got to be able to go to the
legislature and convince them at least
argue with them at least ask ask them to
participate and say look here's why you
should do it
it's leadership and we don't seem to
have that when it comes to guns
you had the NRA which was the leader the
NRA has basically been beaten we've gone
and they've lost most of their funding
sources their top management is in chaos
you think you can work with the NR
no but I don't think I think you can't
avoid the NRA you core you can beat them
I tried to reach out to them many years
ago when I first got into City Hall so
you intend to work around the NRA is
what you're saying well I think you just
don't paint you just don't make much of
the NRA you don't have to go talk to
them at all we're in a state where you
know people embrace their guns here how
do you convince people in a state a
swing state by the way that gun control
is the answer how do you do that we're
not trying to convince them of gun
control those are the wrong words and I
think this has become so hard because we
use words like that well if we don't use
the term gun control what should we use
we want to have background checks we
want to have restrictions on who can buy
and look only in the following sense
nobody's a miner nobody who are
psychiatric problems nobody who has
criminal record it should be allowed to
buy a gun and in fact there's a federal
law that says you can't buy a gun if you
fit any of those three categories at any
gun store across America ever all 50
states and most gun dealers honor that
law yet the shootings can't wait because
there's found other ways other places to
sell guns on the internet and at gun
shows that's where the people that get
the guns that shouldn't have them go
because there is no background check why
is there none because when the law was
written to put background checks in the
internet didn't exist in gun shows
didn't exist why is this issue so
important to you because too many people
are getting killed it is a calamity
across the country particularly in
poorer neighborhoods we are better than
that America is a country that when a
perfect we've had plenty of things in
our background that we should be ashamed
of but we are a country that's
compassionate and we can do better is it
different they are working with the New
York City Council the New York
legislature then it would be working
with Congress and working with a divided
Congress and working with a polarized
nation well number one the head person's
job is to pull people together that's
one of the reasons why I think that
Donald Trump is the total
unsuited to be President of the United
States he does not have the instincts of
pulling people together he prides
himself in dividing them the president
the United States last time I checked
the Constitution he's supposed to be the
president of the whole country no matter
whether you wear a blue tie or a red tie
no matter where in the country you live
I want to talk about you getting in the
race because when you were on CBS this
morning in September are you sitting
here going I wish I had done it now I
never think back there was not a road
for me when Joe was in the race to get
through because we would have split the
votes what happened between September
and now I looked at our national
government getting worse the way we are
behaving overseas and domestically led
by our president
I said back in 2016 he is the wrong
person for the job he doesn't have the
temperament or the ethics the intellect
to do the job and I watched and I said
we just can't have another four years of
this and then I watched all the
candidates and I just thought to myself
Donald Trump would eat him up you think
all the candidates who are running today
he would eat them up let me rephrase it
I think that I would do the best job of
competing with him and beating him one
of the other things you said in
September was that Joe Biden is a friend
did you talk to Joe Biden ahead of time
to say I'm getting in no I did not his
staff certainly knew do you still
consider him a friend yeah sure why
would he not be I don't know I'm
thinking with friends like you who needs
enemies you are friendly with other
great TV presenters morning yes and
you're all competing for the same get
but I'm not trying to take your job well
I'm not trying to take his job either he
doesn't have the job of fresney united
states and neither do i at the moment
the person that has it is Donald Trump
I'm trying to take away the job from
Donald Trump did you not think Joe Biden
could win the nomination I don't know
whether we can win the nomination I'm
not a prognosticator I've got to go out
there and make my case around this
country
to the public and say I think I can do
this here's why here's my experiences in
the past and every candidate has to go
and give those examples of themselves
nobody's saying Mayor Bloomberg meant
they either say oh thank god he's
getting in thank God now I know I'm
going to vote for or I hear what the
hell is he thinking is this a big ego
stroke well how do you respond to both
of those the second one I have the same
rights as anybody else
as a matter of fact I think you know
Sanders has been an American longer than
I have but I'm the second longest
American it does it take an ego yeah I
guess it takes an ego to think that you
could do the job but I you know I look
at a mirror and I say well could I do
the job okay I did this I have 12 years
of experience in City Hall and I think
if you go back today and ask most people
about those 12 years they would say that
not me but the team that I put together
made an enormous difference in New York
City and New York City benefited from it
and continues to benefit from it today
from what we did then and that's the
secret sauce the right leadership in the
right team you think that somebody once
said there's no I in the word team I am
NOT smartest guy in the world but I do
know how to get people to come together
select them and get them adjudicate when
they have problems and find funding for
them and and be a sounding board and
then when a decision has to be made yes
I can make a decision I know how to do
that well it would be no surprise to you
that your fellow candidates are not so
glad to see you get in Elizabeth Warren
suggested you're trying to buy the
election Bernie Sanders says as a
billionaire you can run even the dumbest
person on the earth and pay for it you
see the point they're all making yeah
the point they're making is it's that
way if that know what the point they're
making is it's okay if they ask other
people for all their money and it will
help their careers whereas if somebody
goes out and makes the money themselves
and gives it away I give an ax normally
all my income goes to public health
issues in education and the arts and the
environment things that
care about and I think I could do a lot
of good for the country if I could
become president and so using some of
those monies to fund the campaign is
fine what is true it might marry a sec
time my father made six thousand dollars
the best year of his life I don't come
from money nobody gave me if headstart I
had my parents gave me that education
and public school system and in in
Medford Massachusetts and they taught me
ethics and they taught me hard work I
worked my way through college and then I
worked for 15 years I got fired I
started a company the company turned out
to be phenomenally successful you've
been very success what's wrong with all
of that and then I turn and they're
criticizing me for it I don't know ask
them what they're doing
where did why didn't they do that they
had a chance to go out and make a lot of
money and and how much of their own
money do they put into their campaigns
but I think the point that they're
making a lot of people are making is
you're a billionaire who was buying this
election what is your response to that
I'm not buying anymore I'm doing exactly
the same thing they're doing except that
I am using my own money they're using
somebody else's money who X and those
other people expect something from them
nobody gives you money if they don't
expect something and I don't want to be
bought I didn't take a dime in three
different elections when I was mayor in
New York City and when the lobbyists
came into City Hall they went down to
the other side of City Hall where the
City Council was lobbyists never came to
our side because they know they couldn't
buy anything well because you're not
accepting campaign donations as you laid
out so well it also means that you're
not participating in the debates you
can't purchase they may change the rules
for all I know right now they haven't
changed their rules so how will people
get a chance to meet you and to know you
well number one I'm gonna run ads which
you just talked about I'm gonna fund the
ads but all the ads will be very glowing
about you there's no way anybody can
challenge I'm here you're asking me
questions you can ask me anything you
want I can't think if I don't know if
they're afraid to have you ask them
questions I'm not afraid to ask you
questions you can ask me anything you
want
I don't have to answer it yep but isn't
part of the debate process mayor a
give-and-take with your fellow
candidates there's no debate
there's the come on those they're canned
things they practiced yelling at each
other there's no debate whatsoever I
have a lot more debate with the people
in the audience or the press when I'm
out there and they yell questions at you
there you can have a debate if you want
to call it that way I don't know what's
the Democratic Party's going to do I
suspect as it gets down to some fewer
people they're probably going to change
the rules so that you could participate
without some of the restrictions they
had would you like to participate in the
debate yesterday change the rules I'd be
happy to and if they don't that's okay
too it's up to them they said the
Democratic Party sets the rules for the
Democratic primary Republican one for
their primaries I will be happy to
participate I want to run as a Democrat
I am curious about your strategy because
you you've entered the race late as we
all know you're skipping Iowa New
Hampshire and South Carolina and Nevada
too how are people or were the voters in
those states supposed to feel I'm a dad
I'm gonna go to them I'm gonna go to
each of those four states try to put
together group and let the press be
there and say tell him why I'm skipping
them there isn't enough time for me to
do it I didn't enter it before because I
didn't think there was a need I looked
at this country and said there is a need
I think that we've got to do something
about it I couldn't look in a mirror if
I didn't at least have the guts to go
out and try do it and do it with my own
money and do it with my own time and and
and sacrifice with my family and
everything else and so I'm gonna go do
that let's move on to the President of
the United States do you think President
Trump should be impeached I think it's a
very serious thing but it and I was
before opposed to it but after looking
at all the evidence I think yes sad but
yes what is the biggest thing that
troubles you about him he does not seem
to understand that he is the an elected
official whose job it is to work for the
public rather than for himself has he
done anything or said anything in these
laughs
three years now that you think that was
good congratulations you got that right
anyway mine I think some of his things
make some sense but the trouble is he
can't stop himself from doing them over
doing them or doing them in a ways
that's dysfunctional for example it's
not fair that China allows doesn't allow
certain things for us over there that we
do allow for them over here it's not
fair that they subsidize some industries
the World Trade Organization would stop
some of that it's not fair that they has
tried to steal intellectual property and
so taking on that fight yes I think it's
the right fight to take on the Democrats
were there with them if they don't want
to have him have a win so no but the
trouble is he's doing in a ways that's
dysfunctional the China's never going to
cave and China is going to be a world
power we have to learn how to deal with
them we have to deal with them on things
like climate change and trade and it
often does really come down to
relationships I'm curious what did you
think when you saw world leaders
gossiping really and mocking the
President of the United States and I
think it's fair to say we've lost an
enormous amount of respect around the
world
we were the country that set the ethical
moral work standards and provided
protection so that other countries
didn't have to go build their own
nuclear arms and do a lot of other
things sadly we've lost a lot of that I
think it also goes without saying he's
no fan of yours he recently said many
Mike Bloomberg has instructed his
third-rate news organization not to
investigate him or any Democrat but to
go after president Trump only what sort
well you've got a nickname already
what's your response to well I don't
know that I would accept the nickname I
think people have said to me how can you
investigate yourself and I said I don't
think you can but even your own news
reporters have complained they think
it's unfair that they're not allowed to
investigate other Democratic candidates
because their boss we have I just have
to learn to live with some things they
get a paycheck and it comes from the
company and from the company that I
started not running at the moment turn
over to somebody else to do that but
with with your paycheck comes some
restrictions and responsibilities from
stop-and-frisk you recently apologized
for that
some people are suspicious of the timing
of your apology the mark of a
intelligent competent person is when
they make a mistake they have the guts
to stand up and say I made a mistake I'm
sorry we don't question that we don't
question your belief that you made a
mistake I think the question is the
timing that you realize you made them
nobody asked me about it until I started
running for president so come on are you
saying to people that you realize you
had made a mistake before but you just
didn't mention it until now I think we
were overzealous at the time to do it
our intent was to do anything we could
to stop the carnage the murder rate and
what was surprising is when we stopped
doing it a little bit we thought crime
would go up it didn't it went down so
you know it should have would have been
could have I can't help that but in
looking back made a mistake I'm sorry I
apologize let's go fight the NRA and
find other ways to stop the murders and
incarceration those are things that I'm
committed to do and the more I do that
the better off everybody is the next
debate is December and Cory Booker said
that it could possibly be on that debate
stage no one of color there would be
more billionaires than the race than
black people is that a problem to you
well Cory Booker endorsed me a number of
times and I endorsed Cory Booker a
number times he's very well-spoken he's
got some good ideas it would be better
the more diverse any group is but the
public is out there picking and choosing
and narrowing down this field the truth
of the matter is you had a lot of
diversity in the candidates some of whom
were very competent why they aren't
there as you narrowed it down you have
to talk to other people who are experts
I don't know part of the conversation is
here we go another old white gentleman
isn't it time for change isn't it time
for somebody there you and yes it may be
but lots of people can enter you there
was no reason
if you wanted to enter and run for
president nine states you could have
done that but don't complain to me that
you're not in the race it was up to you
and I thought there was a lot of
diversity in the group of democratic
aspirins entry is not a barrier here so
you're saying if you want diversity then
get in that is exactly a good way to
phrase it thank you very much are you
more inclined to select a woman running
mate or a person of color I my criteria
is plain and simple the following I will
not if I get to the point where I can
pick a Democratic candidate a Democratic
vice-presidential candidate remember the
party would technically have to approve
yes but I would never pick my first my
only criteria is if I drop dead could
the Vice President take over and run
this country such that my kids and
grandkids were safe and had a future
that's the only criteria and you know
you can say what you need somebody's
gonna help you in this state or help you
in that state vice presidential
candidates don't have a big influence on
that and they don't even have an
influence in terms of getting votes for
themselves it's the president
presidential candidate that everybody
talks about and to me the whole purpose
of a vice president is to have somebody
that you can say look I'm gonna go on
vacation for two weeks you're the
president you do it and they don't do
that
they don't do that they send the advice
president off to do some ceremonial
stuff but the staff the president and
the president staff they stay they can't
get up they can't pass the reins they
can't delegate but you're saying you're
vice presidential pick would not be
ceremonial you want somebody who you
know who could do the job I somebody
that I think I would look for candidate
that I think would be better at the job
than me I've always tried to hire people
who are smarter than me and who can take
over from me and that I can learn from
them
and there's lots of female and male
people and male candidates out there and
my list and my mind here to share are
you leaning in I need to thank you not
today I'll get to the next time okay I
want to get to a couple of personal
issues because you would be the first
modern day single president but we all
know in New York you are not an eligible
bachelor your significant other Diana
Taylor is a very accomplished highly
respected highly admired woman would she
be our de-facto first lady is she
playing a role in your campaign she's
playing a role in the campaign number
one number two we've only been living
together for 19 years and I think it's
fair if I can speak for her as well
neither of us have any plans to change
living together we would do you all
think about getting married not a
subject I'm going to discuss with you
dear well I am curious I didn't know
what had been that long okay so you
didn't answer but it only seems like
half that way but you didn't answer the
question which she be our de facto first
lady yes she would do the ceremonial
things that Donald Trump's wife does but
I would use of her I care more about her
judgement I don't always agree with her
so yeah I'm she's just wrong
I think she would say the same about you
and she probably would who is a real
Mike Bloomberg I was thinking you were a
Democrat then you were a Republican then
you were an independent and now you're a
Democrat who are you I am a social
liberal fiscal moderate who is basically
nonpartisan
I grew up as a Democrat in Massachusetts
there are no Republicans I moved to New
York where I was a Democrat there are no
Republicans I couldn't become mayor on
the Democratic line the Republicans said
well you can run as a Republican in New
York City the mayor's job is not a
partisan job so I did but you could have
voted me on a different line we have a
complicated most of America is in the
middle that most people are I do believe
that most of the public is in the middle
what do you think is the biggest
misconception about you you're
well-known in New York but not his name
is Brad Pitt all the time and I just
it's not go for a joke I knew it but I'm
being serious you're well-known in New
York but what is the biggest you know
for some people hearing Michael
Bloomberg from the state of New York
what is the biggest misconception about
you most people would say whether they
like my views or not they would say he's
at least honest and genuine doesn't pull
any punches
hard-working probably say smart but not
everybody would agree with that but I
think they'd all say hard-working and
honest and I like people and I think
nobody expected that what would your dad
William Henry Bloomberg say about you
today I think he was he would say you
know my son shook hands one time with
David Rockefeller and Jacob Rothschild
those would be the two magic names for
some for Jewish guy working his way up
the fact that you could someday meet
them would be inconceivable and yet I
knew David Rockefeller very well he was
a very generous guy gave a lot of money
as does the rest of his family to help
the people in New York and around this
country and around the world same thing
Rothschild I know but think of what he
would think about you today though
honest my mother said don't let it go to
your head that was always her advice and
she was there she held the Bible when I
got sworn in don't let it go to your
head
don't let it go
your head has it no I mean I talked to
her she died not even a little bit I
don't think so
look in the mirror yeah it's okay what I
like today still is Alou started to talk
about liking people every time I walk by
a police officer I stick my hand out
thanks for taking care of us
fire truck stopped I walk over and reach
up to the fire guys thanks for taking
care of us
sanitation worker they stopped the truck
if they don't stop the truck and come
out over and shake take the gloves off
and shake hands I'm annoyed if I go into
your building mm-hmm and you're waiting
for me there
I first shake hands with the doorman I
know I've seen that I've seen that I
want to talk about being the first
Jewish president where anti-semitism is
really high these days sadly it is how
do you tend to address that deal with
that how does that well number one not
be ashamed of Who I am
I'm not a terribly religious person but
I'm very proud of my heritage one story
my father one time at the dining room
table was looking a little booklet that
had been sent out of donors to the
n-double a-c-p and he had given I think
$50 or something and I said to him why
are you giving money to the
n-double-a-cp and he said because
discrimination against anybody is
discrimination against everybody it
sounds like a Martin Luther King quote
to me he would have been very happy to
have said that I'm sure